the jurogan experience you're a funny
guy man and you take you at least used
to take a lot of [ __ ]
and i i never understood i had never
i don't either i never have understood
that but it's mellowed out a little bit
it's kind of like you know you've done
it so long yeah kind of like okay you
can go to the barbecue now you're part
of the club
but um
for years and years i mean uh from from
the very very beginning which is kind of
funny you being a comic but i started in
florida um one thing everybody worried
about was uh was you know fever you know
you want to steal you know i stole zach
so i thought you know not only did i do
my
my thing just because i wanted to do
props but i thought wow no one's going
to hate me because i'm doing
i'm not doing anyone's i mean i'm you
know stealing crime watch signs and [ __ ]
right and lugging around the country so
if anything they would say you know okay
he's not funny or at least he's original
but he's not funny but they would say oh
no he's you know everything they i just
got i would get [ __ ] for like i was the
[ __ ] i was just filling the punch line
just yeah you were you were a whipping
boy yeah you know what it's like you're
like the it's like nickelback for
whatever nickelback takes so much [ __ ]
it's like someone decides that that's a
good punchline you know they're right
characters and i've seen nickelback and
they put on a pretty amazing show
they've got some good songs and they do
they're pop songs yeah but so [ __ ]
what it's like they're not hurting
anybody it was you know so let's say i
would do a show and we have a you know
nice crowd it was great standing ovation
we get on the bus and we're driving to
wherever next gig and we're all watching
you know
the tv and then boom there's a car top
rip and i'd be like you know what the
[ __ ] we just i just not only we just did
a great show we had a whole bunch of
people laughing yeah so
this one guy is telling me you know that
i said whatever you know i've always
been
a guy that's uh considered the source i
mean i was always picked on as a kid but
but when i'd come home my mom was you
know what happened
they who was it was this guy well
consider the source right
yeah it's always been that with with
comedy too like when you know george
carlin said i was funny
that that
negated every every
[ __ ] that said i've sucked i thought
george carlin thought i was funny so
that's oh yeah i always think you know
so you're kind of a good show well you
kind of want
i think most humans want
everyone to love them right yeah so
we're all but as comics we're we're even
more sensitive we want i want i want not
only to have fans
but i want my peers to like me as well
so it's weird and then people say well
who gives a [ __ ] you know
you know you have fans that love you who
cares about
your peers i'm like well you kind of
want other comics to go hey man i dig
your style you know
no for sure that's the thing if you're
rejected by your peers if even if the
rest of the world loves you what comics
hate you right it's horrible it's been
like i said i've kind of i've done it so
long i guess they found like ah [ __ ] he
can stay i guess well i think first of
all you
own the genre now there used to be like
when i started in 88 there used to be
prop comics yeah you became so
successful as a prop comic that you own
the genre like there's no prop comics
anymore man i think i know i don't think
anyone wants to be one
that's what i think they're like [ __ ]
that i'm not going down that path i'm
going to take over all the abuse that i
took i'd tell them don't do it
but when we had though like you said
that rip taylor or yeah um gallagher uh
and by the way gallagher was very much
of an influence
uh on me when i was when i started doing
uh comedy and i and um
i i
i would get uh well i should just tell
you so so
one day gallagher meets me for lunch and
and
gallagher is listening so he um
he's up he's yelling at me and screaming
in front of everybody in front of the
like the valley and he says i stole his
act and i was like gallagher yeah i'll
meet you for lunch to yell at you yeah
well i think we've made up since i think
he came to the show and told me how to
redo it but i know he did
i've heard him
get rid of that sounds [ __ ] get rid
of crazy and and
you know stop doing props so
um
yeah so uh
but the thing that i thought was kind of
funny because i in my defense of
gallagher i used to always say
um
it's not the watermelon that's he's a
very brilliant comic i mean you go back
and listen to his his writing yeah it
was great but all people knew was him
jumping on the big couch and right
hitting the watermelon but i would
always say no that guy's a genius and so
then he meets me and he tells me you
know what you you stole my act and you
didn't steal the you stole the stupid
stuff
and i said we talked well first i didn't
steal anything he says hey the stupid
stuff why didn't you steal the smart
stuff the words the stuff that's
actually clever why would you i said but
i didn't steal it's my stupid stuff i
didn't was he saying you stole my whole
act he said you know you know just that
may be the genre i guess because if you
break down gallagher prop stuff it was
always a pun
it was a shoe horn it was like rip rip
taylor kind of like a it's a butterfly
it's butter with wings and mine was like
no it's a crime watch sign it's a it's a
it's a
it's a it was more of an invention
um prop so he thought that by you know
maybe holding up two things and saying
it's a this and that
i never did that that's what was funny
we never i've never my style of prop
comedy is kind of an interesting it's
like an inventive if you go back and
find a problem no no i haven't there's
always a twist to it it's not just me
holding up a it's not a word play word
like the width you know i was like yeah
i've got my tubes tied and it's just
tubes all together so mauren's like
trying to think what i would have like
uh you know
i don't know like a microphone from mick
jagger that has an oxygen thing in it so
you know so it's it's something it's
something that's more into it anyway
it's just a different same way i get it
when i did it's jokey but
yeah and when i did the family guy
um they said uh they called they said
you know we got the thing all ready and
they sent me the script and i was like
so the joke is it's a see-saw right so
i'm like uh so it's prop is a saw with
glasses on it right and that's kind of
not what i do right
and so i was like oh man this is uh i
don't like this if we change it to
something that i do
and the guys that with this um
mcfarland says um dude no this is
people's [ __ ] great and i said i know
but seesaw is really
stupid
and he says
i wrote it i said no it's not that
stupid then um i said no no i just want
to do so like can i kind of do one of my
props she said well two two things wrong
we already have the animation
done right and secondly everyone loves
it and if you want to do it you know
we'll just get someone else to do the
voice it's fine i said no no i want to
do it i just if we can't [ __ ] it so i
did it and i still to this day get
people going dude see-saw
so they were
they were right
i just uh i just was like damn it i want
it to be a little more whatever i get it
yeah well also
you've got to be a little defensive
after all the years of people [ __ ]
on you yeah yeah yeah
true
you